>>Tonya: I grew up here at Hartville.
I moved here in third
grade and I graduated here.
>>We are kind of your
traditional small town.
We've got our square with
the courthouse on it.
We've got old buildings that have
been around since the Civil War era.
>>When I first came in
the classroom I was one
of those traditional teachers.
I would stand in front of the class.
I would give the notes.
Nothing really ever worked great.
>>And then once eMINTS was brought
in and I went through that training,
learning how to help the
students work in groups,
learning how to guide them.
>>It was amazing to see the
student who was always resistant
to education gradually and slowly
over the school year they start
getting involved with the group
and never been involved
before, start making friends
that had never made friends before.
>>You could see it in the
student's eyes that big "aha" moment
when the light bulb goes off and
you can tell they finally got it.
>>Doug: Well today we're working
with catching up on some websites
that you may or may
not be familiar with.
>>Monica: The biggest thing we
do is help teachers learn how
to be learners again.
>>Doug: Just a second
ago you guys were talking
about what your favorite
part of working
in a technology classroom was.
And so now I want you to think again.
If you could create a word
or a phrase or a picture
to describe what you just talked
about, what would that be?
>>One of the things I do is I
deliver the professional development
for the district teachers.
>>I try to make the trainings
be active and meaningful.
>>Teacher: You know you've got the
live, laugh, learn and the lifetime
because it's a lifetime skill
that we're teaching them.
>>Doug: A lot of times teachers
don't get that opportunity
to just be an instructional
designer with other teachers.
>>Teacher: Enhanced interaction.
>>Teacher: Enhanced
interaction, that's it.
>>Teacher: I like it.
>>Doug: In a typical school day
they may work with children all day
and then when the bell rings and the
students go on the bus they may have
to work by themselves or they
go home and when you come
to an eMINTS training you're
working with your peers.
>>Tonya: They go out and
they collect all this data
and they compile all these graphs
and they put it all together
in the PowerPoint and they have
to stand up and teach the rest
of the class, they have a better
understanding of those concepts
of the scientific method and
how important your hypothesis is
and how you have to follow
that all the way through.
>>Doug: Here's what we will
do next with that word,
phrase or picture is we have a
graffiti wall and we're going to ask
that you come up, select a
pen and either write your word
or write your phrase or draw your
picture on the graffiti wall.
>>Tonya: Doug Caldwell, you know, he
stands up there and he models what
us as teachers should be
doing in the classroom.
After the explore time
he brings us all back
and had us do a graffiti wall, a
sharing what we learned and
talking about as a group
"Here's what I looked at,
what am I going to do with it?"
so that helps me to know that
in my classroom it's important
to get them back in that group and
say "Okay, here's what I've done."
So other students can kind of
like "Oh, I've got an idea now."
>>Monica: It's a two-year program.
The person who is doing their
professional development sessions
facilitating those, comes into their
classroom on at least a monthly basis
so they are very tightly woven with
eMINTS, with their facilitator,
with the materials and with their
colleagues in this learning community
over a period of two years and that's
when the changes begin to take place.
>>Student: Every animal has to have
its adaption to its environment.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Doug: Why do you think
that understanding that all
that stuff you just
mentioned is important?
>>Student: It's
important to know
if the animal can live there or not?
>>Tonya: What I want you to
do now is I need you to come up
with either a picture or a word
that represents what
you just talked about.
>>What has helped me is, I choose one
thing, maybe one lesson I really want
to work on and I work on it
and I get it done and I use it
with the students and then
I'll move on to another lesson.
>>Doug: We're bringing technology
to the rural school, instead
of throwing a teacher in
that room and saying "Hey,
enjoy all your new tools."
We try to talk about, during the
trainings, how we will use the tools,
how would students use the tools?
What is the role of the teacher?
What is the role of the technology?
>>Doug: I saw your entry point
where you used the graffiti wall.
>>Tonya: Yes that was a
really neat thing last night.
I really liked using it
so I really enjoyed it.
It helped us focus our attention on
our unit so I think it's a great-
I'm hoping to use it more.
>>I have discovered that if
students are digging and finding it
for themselves they will
learn it much better.
So it has really changed
my view of education.
>>Doug: A teacher met me in the
teacher's lounge and she was crying.
She said "That was the most
powerful thing I've ever done.
I really took a chance.
I wasn't sure that my students
would respond, but I followed
through then the students
generated some terrific questions.
And there are things that I wouldn't
have thought of as an adult."
And it was really meaningful to the
students because they were trying
to solve problems that
meant something to them.